something I hear so often on the show
they'll be like Pearl Pearl how do you
know the man won't just switch up when
we're married and this is what I say is
that oftentimes women will marry a man
and he shows you exactly who he is and
then women want to whine later about
their choices so what happened
um Kim marries Kanye and towards the end
of the relationship a big stress was
Kanye being very eccentric he would post
tweets about their marriage and they
were very public but this was a very
hard time in their marriage so
how could he just switch up and publicly
blast out all their information Kanye
was never eccentric